del lado izquierdo tenemos una forma de
representar a la molécula de etano el
problema con este dibujo es que no nos
da mucha información de cómo se ve el
etano en tres dimensiones del lado
derecho tenemos otro dibujo o proyección
de la molécula de etano esta proyección
nos da más información es una proyección
de cuñas y líneas recuerden que la cuña
significa que el enlace sale del plano
está hacia nosotros la línea punteada
significa que el enlace se aleja de
nosotros queda hacia atrás del plano y
una línea simple significa que el enlace
se encuentra en el plano esta proyección
representa a una de las conformaciones
del etano las conformaciones son los
diferentes arreglos de un átomo que
resultan de la rotación de un em
sabemos que este enlace simple carbono
carbono puede rotar libremente esta
proyección de cuña representa una de las
posibles con formaciones y si rotamos
este enlace carbono carbono obtendremos
diferentes conformaciones esto es más
fácil de explicar con un modelo
molecular en un momento les mostraré un
vídeo para que podamos ver las
diferentes conformaciones del etano a
estos hidrógenos los vamos a identificar
de color verde
entonces los hidrógenos en verde serán
los que están unidos a este carbón que
es el carbono frontal y los hidrógenos
unidos al carbono de atrás serán de
color blanco entonces veamos el vídeo y
observen las diferentes conformaciones
del etano
y aquí tenemos la conformación alternada
del etano viéndola desde la proyección
de cuña si la giramos un poco ahora
podemos ver la proyección de caballete y
si alineamos a los carbonos podemos ver
una tercera proyección de esta molécula
se llama proyección de newman si tomamos
uno de los hidrógenos y lo giramos sin
mover el carbono de atrás solo rotamos
el carbono de adelante cada vez que lo
rotamos hay una conformación diferente
así que en realidad hay muchas posibles
con formaciones aquí he regresado a la
posición original
esta es la conformación alternada o
escalonada otra conformación que nos
interesa es la conformación eclipsada
simplemente rote uno de los hidrógenos
verdes para que se alineará con algunos
de los hidrógenos blancos
es la conformación eclipsada en la
proyección de newman y voy a girar esto
un poco para que puedan observar cómo se
ve en una proyección de caballete y
finalmente si la vuelvo a girar esta es
la conformación eclipsada en la
proyección de cuña
ahora que ya vimos el vídeo analicemos
las tres proyecciones para la
conformación alternada del etano
empecemos con la proyección de cuña y
líneas observen que este hidrógeno este
carbón este carbono y este hidrógeno se
encuentran en el mismo plano por eso
estos enlaces están dibujados con líneas
simples si analizamos el carbono de la
izquierda sabemos que hay un hidrógeno
verde hacia nosotros también hay un
hidrógeno verde lejos de nosotros y este
hidrógeno se encuentra en el plano
para los hidrógenos blancos este
hidrógeno se encuentra en el plano este
hidrógeno está hacia nosotros y este
hidrógeno está lejos de nosotros es más
fácil verlo en la fotografía
simplemente relacionamos los dibujos con
las fotografías la siguiente es la
proyección de caballete este carbono
corresponde a este carbono que está
unido a tres hidrógenos verdes verde
verde y verde también tenemos este
enlace carbono carbono que corresponde a
este enlace en nuestra proyección de
caballete y finalmente en el carbono de
atrás tenemos a nuestros hidrógenos de
color blanco
si observamos el enlace carbono carbono
desde aquí es decir si vemos la molécula
desde esta perspectiva lo que veríamos
es la proyección de newman entonces este
punto representa al carbono frontal es
decir a este carbón vamos a escribirlo
este punto representa al carbono frontal
y el carbono frontal está unido a los
hidrógenos verdes así que este es un
hidrógeno verde también este y este el
carbono frontal bloquea al carbono de
atrás no podemos ver al carbono de atrás
en esta imagen pero sabemos que ahí está
así que en la proyección de newman este
círculo representa al carbono de atrás
lo escribiré este círculo es el carbono
de atrás
aun cuando no podemos verlo el carbono
de atrás está unido a los hidrógenos de
color blanco así que este es un
hidrógeno blanco al igual que este y
este observen que podemos ver los
hidrógenos en blanco por aquí y sabemos
que están unidos a un carbono aunque no
lo podamos ver y hablando de
proyecciones de newman hablemos sobre el
ángulo que hay entre este hidrógeno
blanco y este hidrógeno verde el ángulo
entre estos dos es de 60 grados
tenemos un ángulo de 60 grados entre
estos dos hidrógenos este es el ángulo
piedra o de torsión ángulo tierra
o ángulo de torsión
este ángulo es muy importante cuando
hablamos de conformación es observen que
los hidrógenos están separados en la
proyección de newman los hidrógenos
verdes se encuentran alternados con los
hidrógenos blancos
todos estos hidrógenos estan alternados
y por eso se le llama conformación
alternada finalmente echemos un vistazo
a la conformación eclipsada empecemos
con nuestra proyección de cuña aquí
tenemos este hidrógeno este carbono este
carbono y este hidrógeno en el mismo
plano y por eso tenemos estos enlaces
dibujados con líneas simples para el
carbono de la izquierda observen que
tenemos un hidrógeno verde hacia
nosotros que sería este hidrógeno
también tenemos un hidrógeno lejos de
nosotros que sería
de hidrógeno y este hidrógeno se
encuentra en el plano ahora este
hidrógeno blanco se encuentra en el plan
este hidrógeno está hacia nosotros y
este hidrógeno está lejos de nosotros
para la proyección de caballete
este es el carbono frontal que sería
este carbón y está unido a los
hidrógenos verdes entonces tenemos un
hidrógeno hacia arriba uno hacia arriba
este hidrógeno está hacia abajo y hacia
la derecha y este hidrógeno está hacia
abajo y hacia la izquierda después
tenemos el enlace carbono carbono que
corresponde a este enlace y luego
tenemos el carbono de atrás que está
unido a tres hidrógenos blancos
2 y 3 que corresponden a estos
hidrógenos finalmente veamos la
proyección de newman recuerden que para
ver la proyección de newman tenemos que
ver el enlace carbono carbono desde esta
perspectiva
entonces si analizamos el enlace carbono
carbono desde aquí lo primero que vemos
es al carbono frontal que corresponde a
este carbono y el carbono frontal está
unido a los hidrógenos de color verde 1
2 y 3 que serían 1 2 y 3 entonces estos
son los enlaces entre el carbono frontal
y los hidrógenos por otro lado no
podemos ver al carbono de atrás pero
sabemos que se representa con este
círculo y sabemos que está unido a los
hidrógenos blancos
qué serían estos hidrógenos
ahora si pensamos en el ángulo entre los
hidrógenos el ángulo es de 0 grados
porque este hidrógeno está perfectamente
alineado con el hidrógeno de atrás
entonces los hidrógenos verdes están
alineados con los hidrógenos blancos y a
esto le llamamos conformación eclipsado